ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Hello, and welcome
to another great episode
of Google Developers Live.
My name is Arun Nagaranjan
with the Google Apps developer
relations team.
And it's actually a
really special episode.
We have a great partner
here, HelloSign,
and they're going to walk
us through a great add-on
that they've build
for Google Docs.
Before we get started, I want
them to introduce themselves.
NEAL O'MARA: I'm Neal
O'Mara, from HelloSign,
one of the co-founders.
JOSEPH WALLA: And
I'm Joseph Walla,
and I'm also one
of the co-founders.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Awesome.
We have the co-founders
of great HelloSign here.
Can you tell me a little
bit about your roles
within the company
and what you work on?
NEAL O'MARA: Yeah,
so I'm the CEO.
Neal's the CTO.
And Neal works on all
the technical side,
and I work in the business side.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Awesome, awesome.
So for the folks that
don't know HelloSign,
can you tell a bit about
what HelloSign does
and what some of your
products focus on?
NEAL O'MARA: Yeah, definitely.
So HelloSign is the easiest
way to sign documents online.
Traditionally, whenever
you had to sign a document,
you'd have to print, sign,
and scan the document.
And so what we did is we
made it so you could sign it
all from your computer.
You could sign digitally,
or from your phone, as well.
And what was exciting
about this specific add-on
is that, also, you can sign
it directly from Google Docs.
I suppose we can talk
about that in a little bit.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, that's great.
So before we dig into some
of the details of the add-on,
let's do a quick demo.
Let's take a look at
what it looks like,
and then we can kind of dissect
some of the internals of it.
JOSEPH WALLA: All right.
Let's go to the demo.
So we kind of have two
main workflows here.
And one of them is, you
need to sign a document,
and you need to
send it to someone.
So, for example, maybe
you have an offer letter,
and you need to send it out.
And it's nice to sign the offer
letter before you send it.
So in Google Docs, you can pull
up HelloSign Sign document.
It shows the sidebar, and in
this case who needs to sign,
is just me.
So once you pull that up, it
will pull any saved signatures
you have from your
HelloSign account.
In this case, I have
Harry Truman's signature.
So you can just
drag and drop that
straight into the document,
sign it right there.
It's really great, really
easy functionality.
Resize it and make it a little
nicer, and there you go.
You have a signed document.
If you don't have
any saved signatures,
you can draw a new signature.
So that will pop up a modal,
where with a HTML5 Canvas,
you can add your signature.
And you can save that,
and drag it back on.
And then you can
email it out as a PDF,
if you don't want to
share an editable Google
Doc with the person.
So then the other
flow really leverages
HelloSign, and our functionality
about getting other people
to sign.
So in this case,
maybe you have an NDA,
and you need your
partner to sign the NDA.
So in this case, we just
need someone else to sign,
so we're going to
choose just others.
So in this case,
what we're doing is
we're processing the
document on our side,
converting it to a format that
we can display to other people.
And once that's ready,
we just hit Continue,
and this is going to take
you over to HelloSign.
And you can type in
who needs to sign.
This can be multiple people.
In this case, we'll just do
one person that needs to sign.
So I'll just do Neal plus John.
You can also cc people as well.
So I'll accept
there, and continue.
And then your document, just
as it was in Google Docs,
is pulled up here.
And then you can specify
where people need to sign,
maybe they need
to fill in things,
maybe they need to date things.
So in this case, let's just have
this person fill in their name,
and then let's have
them add a signature.
So easy as that, and
you hit Continue.
And here you can tell
them what the document
is, give them some instructions.
So, please sign and return.
And then you're
done, easy as that.
You're back In--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
So you started your
authoring process
in Google Docs, formatted
it the way you wanted it,
and then you kicked
it off into HelloSign.
JOSEPH WALLA: Yeah, and
the great thing about this,
is if you also integrate
with our drive integration,
once this gets signed
on their side, that
will be automatically
synced back into Drive.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
So you're tying all the add-ons,
and the integrations together.
JOSEPH WALLA: Yeah, that's
one of the great things
about the Google platform.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Awesome.
That's really awesome.
Thank you very
much for that demo.
So tell me a little bit about
some of the technical pieces.
What are some of the interesting
points about the integration?
Are there anything that
you found surprisingly
great to use or challenging?
JOSEPH WALLA: Yes,
so one of the things
that was really great
for us was being
able to do the drag-and-drop
of a signature.
Google has basically
built-in functionality
that you guys have
provided us with.
So that was great.
In terms of how we built it,
we leveraged a lot of our API.
We have a publicly accessible
API, so a lot of that
was already built,
involving around us fetching
the signatures that are
associated with the person's
account, and sending the
document out for someone else
to sign.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: When
you launch this add-on,
what are some of the
interesting metrics
you'll be paying attention to?
What will be a success for you?
NEAL O'MARA: Yeah,
so we always look
at three different metrics.
One is just top
of funnel growth,
so how many new
users are coming in.
The second is user activity.
And then the third
is monetization.
So how many paid
plans are signing up?
So we've done multiple
Google integrations, now.
We've integrated with
Gmail, Drive, Google Apps,
and this will be our fourth one.
And usually when we
compare all these numbers
to people who just come
to the site and sign up,
usually it's a lot better.
People are generally
more engaged.
Usually they upgrade more.
So all those key metrics
that we look for,
are usually quite good
when we do integrations.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
Thank you very much for
coming into the studio,
and walking us through your
process, and your add-on,
itself.
And good luck with the launch.
NEAL O'MARA: Yeah,
thanks for having us.
We appreciate it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank you.